it was great to see how NBC Sunday Night
Football play-by-play he always stands
up he's a champion for the rights of the
dance he just wants to make sure they're
taking care of you somehow feel like
they're not taken care of
I've made their lives great yeah they go
to Panda Express
Fritzie goes to Panda Express but he
could have gone to a great dinner last
night good huh you know here's the deal
great restaurants in LA as you know I
was listening to you guys early on and
Express is as good a Chinese restaurant
as division was Angeles there you go I
grew up in New York and I love you know
the regular Chinese like shun Lee when
we're back there is fantastic shrimp
with lobster sauce and all the good
stuff this is too many hoity-toity s out
here so my granddaughter turns 8 today
we may be at Panda Express tonight in
the South Bridge he'll be there hey you
read a big rush to make fun of every
little thing I do I know the maitre d
there just today you can I get an extra
order in right now - uh we had a
neighbor draft last week by the way who
would you want is your neighbor famous
person so I took Brady because I get
brady and giselle
he's the neighborhood quarterback for us
like a quarterback both teams Satan took
Chris Pratt because you got on a ferris
his wife to go along with that
Paulie took Dale Earnhardt jr. and Paul
Rudd but I would have al Michael you
just I know as soon as you walked up
Paulie goes and I should have taken out
Michaels in my neighbor drown I bet Alec
had a fantastic grill in his backyard I
just know it
you know nice grilling Aaron used
because we're here exactly we're at the
SCOTUS Cutlass every night I haven't
been Justice Connor since last night if
I can live if I could live next door to
somebody maybe Jeff Bezos because I know
I could always you know get a loan if I
need one yeah okay
somebody like that okay so you don't
want a famous friend like Hollywood
friend no you want to monetary somebody
who I could rely on for my day trading
okay we're for a really good tip like
Warren Buffett would be yeah he's kind
of meant maybe Warren Buffett or
somebody of that ilk or you know one of
the top hedge Flynt it's fun guys you
know one of the guys who makes makes
and beach the market which is very tough
to do these days as you know but are you
in a famous neighborhood well I live in
in West LA yeah we've got some famous
people around us who's on your street
well for a number of years when we moved
in
Rod Stewart had the house next door but
he had divorced Alana Stewart at that
point so Alana on the house but she was
a great neighbor and then Melissa
Etheridge moved in because he was my
neighbor for a while and now I've got a
hedge fund guy next door to me
but I never see him now we have there
are a number of people in that
neighborhood you're not allowed to
mention those names I'm not only maybe
you know Adam Sandler can refer to
whoever he lives next I think Sandler
bought all the houses around him he may
have yeah so nobody lives next to him i
you know i he's got a compound he does
have it I think he has a compound well
because you star in so many of his
movies true by the way how did you do in
his movies you still get residuals from
Luton yeah I got a residual check the
other day four seriously 63 cents you
know for doing a voiceover on on full
house which was like what 20 years ago
what's a stamp these days it's got to be
like 60 cents I'm guessing I I don't my
residual checks from Sandler are not big
yeah I I got a couple of them like
Letterman I'd get like 23 cents right
that would be the residual Studios keep
all them on yeah they do you know that
and Sandler keeps all the money tonight
I mean Dan Dierdorf Frank Aaron and I
had a fairly significant role in Jerry
Maguire which was like 150 150 million
dollar movie yeah and we each made like
2000 what did you think of that movie
Maguire Jerry Maguire at that time I was
surprised because I said who's
interested in how an agent you know
comes into prominence but it was cool
and people loved it and Tom Cruise was
terrific in it and that was Renee
Zellweger's first real big role so that
got her career started and movie was now
how do they how they have they sued us
yeah we went to I guess Sony I came
member where we went to
went to one of the studios in town here
and we were here for about a day and a
half and they set up a fold broadcast
booth and then they had us just you know
announced the game and that's what we
did the interesting thing was the script
was so terrible things we would never
say you know just playing announcer kind
of thing so we wound up just living the
way we would normally have done at that
point Monday Night Football so not only
did we activate and work for just about
scale Plus $23 but we wrote it as well
it was perfect well when they try to
write you know your language or how you
would speak it nobody's going to capture
that like you guys will capture that
exactly but they let you freestyle a
little bit well we at a certain point we
were laughing through you know big the
script as we were reading it in saying
and I think I said to the producer we
would never do this and he said well why
don't you guys just gonna do what you
would do and that and that's how it
happened how many movies have you been
besides bass ketball Jerry Maguire don't
ever forget oh my god you know I
couldn't I didn't watch the movie yep I
heard I don't know how many decades I
didn't watch the movie BASEketball I'm
on vacation in Ireland yep and we're at
this medieval castle where they reenact
you know what it's a medieval dinner and
they serve your glug or whatever and
then this woman with a heavy accent goes
I loved you in BASEketball I don't know
what she's I feel like it sounded like I
love you you're basketball and I go
thank you thank you and then I remember
my son goes no she likes you in the
movie BASEketball I was shocked that
somebody saw it and it's a woman in
Ireland who's the one that said I loved
you in that movie this thing was a
monster hit yes Susan County Court but
you had just had those talented guys and
what they've done with their careers
insane like they've big that mean that
movie I can only tell you was so bad so
bad it was good you know I think they're
so bad it's good these were so crazy and
they kinda liked this show and conscious
and conscious and I you know we we were
there filming
last day of it yeah so I mean they were
rapping and and there was no further
production to be done and we thought our
careers are over we really did well that
line no Costas is yes ya feel really
sniffles yes yeah and and you see they
had the wrong inflection too because I
just feel the nipple so Bob can never I
mean it was we had a lot of fun it the
day started out we were there at seven
o'clock in the morning of Universal and
we were laughing crazily through the
whole thing and then we got to lunch and
we were getting a little tired and then
- - awesome - let us you know have a
little break before they were ready for
the afternoon shooting they showed us
some of the dailies and that's when Bob
and I thought we're done we are here
tonight yes Holly sandy I team has Al
Michaels IMDB and he was in arles Spin
City coach Jerry McGuire who's the boss
life goes on then back it says here on
your IMDB you played Dave Bronstein in
Hawaii five-o in 1970 I did I know in
Hawaii I was in Hawaii I started my
career there and I was doing minor
league baseball University of Hawaii
football I was on television twice a day
and so they were hiring a lot of the
people from the news to do you know bit
parks in Hawaii five-o and Jack Lord was
the star of Hawaii five-o I played a
public defender in fact if you go to
youtube you can see the clip it's like I
play Dave Ronson I was yeah URI I know
you are all over that's my head I have
somebody sent it to me it's Pete Rose's
favorite clip I mean every time he sees
me I get an email or a phone call from
Pete he loves it he can't believe it but
the greatest thing about that I was so
nervous I mean look at kam Fong as Chin
Ho was that like in the credits is that
I just was I used to watch the Wi-Fi
Paulie could you check is it somebody in
there kam Fong as Chin Ho checking yeah
sorry but but the the thing I remember
most about that is I going in there and
you know Jack Lord was like larger than
life and he was a little off-putting I
walked in and he
hi how are you the whole thing that he
could barely say hello can't [ __ ] came
you remember the whole thing there was a
real champion ho there as well - who
owned the baseball team so we're ready
to shoot the scene and I'd studied like
crazy and didn't want to make any
mistakes and they'd roll action and I
have a couple of lines and all of a
sudden Jack - the word goes cut like
that so I think I'm fired you know right
off the bat and Lord had his hand up
like this and he looks at the makeup
person behind the camera goes I think I
need more hand to makeup okay wait a
second so we cut this and how a jacket
Lord know he needed more hand makeup on
his hand was like this so that was my my
debut and most recently I guess the
movie miracle played a role in that so
I've been around the block yeah you have
when we come back I'm gonna ask you some
sports related stuff including if we
stop testing for marijuana in the NFL
how big outcry would that be also LeBron
James where he is is there a way to get
up on the pedestal with Michael Jordan
so a few things talked to Albie know
about Albie no el-medina
Dennis Miller gave you that I certainly
did yeah and alfalfa was given to me by
Bob Uecker
I prefer alfalfa but if you want to go
me I'll be no that's okay um Tina
alfalfa now Michael's more without
coming up Adam Sandler's in the building
he'll join us coming up top of the hour
here dr. Joe when you play golf do
people expect you to be like do better
Cole
no nobody federal I guess but do they
want you to do something where you're
actually a play-by-play voice or
occasionally well I wanted to playing
with Jim Nantz this past weekend of at
Pebble Beach and I was calling his shots
right a tradition like unlike any other
did he say hello friend money that's
connect only car today hello phrase a
great guy you know we the Tony Romo
thing is really interesting as you know
how would you because it was a delicate
time there for Jim because I saw him at
Pebble Beach and and you know trying to
say because he was going to join us on
the air and then he said I need to sort
this out a little bit here I need to
know everything involved in it but have
you ever been involved in a situation
where you had almost it felt like a
palace coup here it may have but I think
you know the the powers that be as CBS
had something in mind look here's what I
think about Tony number one he would
have been my first draft choice among
active players to be a great analyst I
mean he will be Tony will be outstanding
now at first everybody's going to go
well wait a second he what is this all
about because you get used to a certain
voice and a certain style and a certain
type of Rod cast so it'll be different
and Tony's really smart he's got a great
sense of humor he will work his butt off
but you know what you have to learn the
mechanics of the business as you all
know the rhythm of what's going on
Jim Nantz will be a great partner for
him and you know I remember I had Earl
Weaver after Earl had retired for the
first time as the Orioles manager and he
came into the Monday Night Baseball
booth with us and after about three or
four games I would look at Earl and he
wasn't moving his head and he'd see the
veins popping out of his neck and I said
Earl I should why don't you move your
head he was afraid that the headset
would fall off so these are the things
that nobody thinks about when you go
into the booth so Tony will learn on the
fly he'll learn quickly and I think
it'll be terrific over time but this is
what I don't understand if you're doing
a big game I know you can enhance a big
game but I'm still going to watch a big
game right I would have put Tony Romo in
the studio because you you don't have to
like Charles Barkley like you you tune
into a studio show you you're going to
tune into the game you may not tune into
the studio show I could use him put him
on camera he looks good
so I would think I could get more
mileage out of that Tony Rome own studio
and keep Phil Simms as my my color
gunner I don't know the internals of
what took place there but I maybe Tony
wanted to do games you know there there
are guys who come off the field and
would rather be in the studio and there
were guys who would rather do the games
you know I mean to me I've been a guy
and I've done both you know enough
studio especially you know with you in
the Olympics and things like that
but I prefer to be in the game that's
where the action is yeah I love
the buzz and the excitement so I'm not
saying that that necessarily was what
Tony wanted to do but wasn't it was an
opportunity for him and I you know it
made it
I think easier for him to make the
decision that he made instead of going
back to play you know for whoever he was
going to play for when they came to him
and said we're gonna put you under more
well I understand why you'd want to do
games as opposed to studio but if I'm a
studio head I want to see Tony Romo not
just here Tony Romo and that's where I
thought if you put him on the pregame a
couple of things if the NFL stopped
testing for marijuana right what would
the reaction be short term long term two
days story I think everything's a two
day story these days so people would
talk about it I don't think it would be
a long-term issue I mean people would
say oh this is this is good this is bad
whatever but the NFL has gotten through
everything the lease almost bulletproof
I mean and in a man but maybe it's a bad
choice yeah yes yes in today's Vegas
world I just don't think it's that big
of a deal but when you do it for the
fans I'm saying for the fans yeah and I
don't think I think the opiate issue is
a whole lot bigger right with the NFL
but when you do a game and you know
let's say you have Joe Mixon in the
Bengals I don't think I have a bengal
game this this year on Sunday Night
Football do is one on Thursday Thursday
Night Football packages but how much
does Joe Mixon what happened in Oklahoma
come into play a lot of these guys
garyun connelly accused of rape not
charged with rape but accused of that
like how much do you work this in how
important is that to the broadcast well
number one as you all know and you and I
have discussed this the game itself
remember you have a play and then you
might have 30 seconds of inaction and
there's normally a replay involved so
that's the only time you can kind of
weave things in and out look Fred
Goodell is our producer he does a
masterful job we had a game this year
I missed that game but Mike Tirico did
it with Chris and Michele Tafoya Tyriq
Hill yeah at a big game so you had a
deal with Tyreke Hill so what do you do
I think it was woven in and out as well
as you could possibly do it perfectly
but those stories are stories
you can develop on the pregame show or
halftime because during the game itself
people are kind of half listening to the
stories you have to really be careful
and you can't you know you just can't go
away from the game people have tuned in
to watch the game they don't want to be
lectured but clearly if you're dealing
with a mixin or somebody like that or a
great hearty when he was with Dallas you
had to deal with it but you have to do
it very deftly and carefully and make
your points cogently and very quickly -
and you know fidelity is the greatest at
making sure we kind of weave we weave
that in without taking it away from the
game because people want to watch the
game would Michael Jordon be lovable
embraceable now with today's social
media because I look at LeBron I don't
think he's embraceable I don't I don't
think fans love him
I think there's respect I don't know if
there's love where there's so much
admiration for Jordan but would you
think we would treat him the same today
well you know if you go back to that
time when when Michael was playing
they'd over there were they were nation
there's always they're always going to
be naysayers you know that we live in
this world of I call it antisocial media
right when people just want to blast
people around the clock this is what it
is yeah so no matter I mean you mother
Teresa is still going to get ripped on
on anti social media you know that yeah
so nobody's perfect no you know envy and
jealousy are incurable and so there are
people who just want to blast you and
now in today's world you have this
little forum where you can sit you know
in your basement and rip the hell out of
somebody and feel good about it
we should see it back on your computer
screen so you know I think LeBron look I
think LeBron is recognized generally
extremely favorably and should be you
know he had that one you know that that
one misstep with the the decision was
you know horrible concept terribly
produced a situation I'm sure if we had
to do it all over again but you can't I
mean so that that's one thing in this
gigantic career in this great body of
work and he's a phenomenal player and I
know him a little bit and I seems like a
really good guy to me and I just think
you know when
and it's all over and done with 20 years
from now we'll think about LeBron in the
same manner that we think about Jordan
right now what if you were asked to host
the decision and in by LeBron or ESPN
and they want you to drag it out because
that that's they wanted to drag it out
and Jim Gray was the host there right
would they let myself in that position
he would not because that's not you know
that's that's a a that's not journalism
that's whatever the hell it is it's fake
news yeah is what it basically is right
well there's a whole bunch of garbage
that went around - you know I'm gonna
take my talents to South Beach yeah and
even whoever came up with that phrase
for him I mean what the hell is that you
know what was that I'm going to Miami
period you know what take what you
couldn't had an hour-long special al if
they do so rekt and LeBron what's your
decision I'm going to Miami all right
right thank you for joining us via bite
your nails and all of those nonsense
appreciated it
I I like that it was the Boys and Girls
Club of Greenwich Connecticut it's right
right I'm gonna go write hardcore right
it's really sometimes at the Boys and
Girls Club of Greenwich a kinetic write
all these sons and daughters of hedge
fund managers right yeah exactly can you
stick around of course I want to ask you
Kentucky Derby store how many derbies
were you involved in 15 in a row between
86 and mm all right welcome back with Al
Michaels Adam Sandler a little under the
weather but he's a gamer he'll join us
top of the hour here at virtue we
brought this up yesterday yeah
many happy feet he needed more hand
makeup you know what's really sad right
now is Adam Sandler can't sit alone in a
write by yourself
I like Al Michaels and I some locks and
there's a half a bagel in there for you
I'll be back thank you yeah salmon do
you want to work your shift and take my
seat here oh no no but I'm worried for
you I feel fine
I keeps back in the green room all by
himself because he normally pays people
to stay with him and laugh at all his
jokes
and he couldn't get anybody to get up
this early right I have my wife halfway
[Music]
Sandler you'll get your airtime no no no
Netflix wanted me to get on as much as
possible all right yeah yeah well done
we were talking about sports jeopardy
and I was wondering if you went
head-to-head with Bob Costas how would
you do he I think he'd win right now I
think I've forgotten more than I
remember but you've done more events
than Bob different events than Bob I
have but Bob you know Bob still I think
retains as much as anybody but you had
asked me in the break yeah who would
also be I'll tell you what if you played
baseball trivia if I could put constants
against who George Bush 43 siree and who
would you take close I got to tell you
something I mean speaking of la Country
Club I had the great pleasure of playing
with 43 about two months ago did you see
Ronald Reagan's locker there I did yeah
I did I had the whole lockers down but I
played the South Course with 43 and we
for four hours went back and forth like
two kids with baseball cards because I
remember and he remembers almost every
player from the 60s and some from the
50s so I would go to him Chieko counter
skill he went great you know Gus journey
I went outfield of Philadelphia and then
I said to him this is this is the man
who is the president United States for
years I went wolf troppo he goes moose
from Connecticut he remembered it
everything so we only stumped each other
I think once or twice over for hours but
we were like a couple of kids with their
baseball cards throwing memes back and
forth at each other any Pasco you name
it and I mean this is the you know Alpha
Kaka version of playing the baseball
trivia but I would put George Bush in a
contest with anybody on baseball I got
90 seconds left your favorite Kentucky
Derby story is what first one I did 1986
bill shoemaker one of the all-time
greats is on an 18 to 1 shot on the rail
Ferdinand want it and baby when you got
18 to 1 on shoemaker you better load up
I'll never bet on
that was the first and I did son I did
the son of the Sunday silence easy goer
series I did 44 Triple Crown races in
the rope and Tirico gets to do is first
oh yeah nice making his debut as it gave
you it's a lot of fun but he was writer
listen to what he said
you sit within Millionaire's Row get
dressed up guys you know they'll give
you the love you feel how didn't answer
if you had any money on Ferdinand there
we go swimming and bucks only ten at
that point you know was it making a
difference Al Michaels NBC Sunday Night
Football thank you for stopping by and
great to see you always the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience